الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه تنطلق اليوم
وايضا يقول ان الديمقراطيه على المحاك
وترامب ينهي جولته الانتخابيه من
مكرونيه بالعالم
روسيا لمفاوضات حقيقيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نصره الله من العربيه
الانتخابيه يتوجه الامريكيون الى صناديق
الاقتراع اليوم
لاعضاء مجلس النواب وثلث اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ ومسؤولين اخرين وكذلك التصويت على
عده مبادرات ومشاريع قوانين ويجري تصويت
على جميع مقاعد مجلس النواب البالغ عددها
مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ البالغ عدده 100 ويتم
تصويت على 34 مقعدا من مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ
مع العلم ان عضو هذه الهيئه التشريعيه
يخدم لمده ست سنوات اما عضو مجلس النواب
فيخدم لمده عامين وكان اكثر من 42 مليون
امري باصواتهم قبل انتخابات التجديد نصفين
عبر التصويت الشخصي
[موسيقى]
وعشره الانتخابات حظر
من اثار الديمقراطي في مهرجان الانتخابي
في ولايه ميريلاند نحن
هذه اللحظه هي فرصتكم للدفاع
وبتزوج مع ذلك انخفضت شعبيه الريس
الامريكي هذا الاسبوع لتقترب من قدام
مستوياتها خلال فتره رئاسه وذلك قبل يوم
واحد فقط على انتخابات التجديد النصفي
للكونغرس وخلاص الذي اجرته رويترز
على مدار يومين الى ان 99% من الامريكيين
يتفقون مع اداء الوظيفي واسامه انخفاض
شعبيه الرئيس الامريكي
مايو في اثاره التوقعات بفقدان حزبه
السيطره على مجلس النواب في انتخابات
اليوم وربما مجلس الشيوخ ايضا
في يناير 20 21 في خيطان
عانت ولايه بايرن من الاثار الاقتصاديه
للازمه الصحيه العالميه ومنها ارتفاعه
مستويات تضخم واستطلع المسح الذي اجري عبر
الانترنت في الولايات المتحده
هل في شخص بينهم
424 مؤيدا للحزب الديمقراطي و 390 مؤيدا
للحزب الجمهوري
وفي المقابله على الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي توجه الى ولايه انه
سيصدر اعلانا هاما جدا في الخامس عشر من
نوفمبر الجاري وسط التكاثر بانه قد يكشف
عن خوده الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 20 24
خطب الرئيس الامريكي السابق ساره
على دعمهم للمرشح لجمهوري
ديفاير فارس
الجمهوريين في استعادته مجلس النواب مجلس
الشيوخ
[تصفيق]
اهلا وسهلا في مقاطعه الامريكيه بولايه
اريزونا التي تشهد منافسه مقتدمه في
الانتخابات النصفيه تعزيز الاجراءات
الامنيه قبل فتح صناديق الاقتراع اليوم
وحضر مسؤولو الولايه من ان لديهم صفر
تسامح تجاه كل من يحاول ترهيبا ناخبين
وقال قائد شرطه المقاطعه شرف بول صحفيين
سيكون لدينا صفر تسامح مضيفا لدى الكثير
او لدي الكثير من الزلزالات لمن يختارون
القدوم الى هنا ومخالفه
التي يبلغ عدد سكانها اربعه ملايين 500
الف نسمه توتورا وتزايدا منذ انتخابات عام
بسبب اعلان الحزب الجمهوري في الولايه عدم
ثقته بنظام
سيطره الجمهوريه على الكونجرس بعد
انتخابات التجديد النصفي ستمثل اهداف ضغط
قويه على اداره رئيس جمهيدن فيما يخص
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا التي وصلت
الى نحو 60 مليار دولار
مساعدات عسكريه قدرت بمليارات الدولارات
قدمتها اداره الرئيس
الامريكيين السيطره الكامله على الكونجرس
في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
خصوصا بعد التصريحات التي اثارتها النائبه
الجمهوريه مارجري تايلور جرين في تجمع
حاشد بولايه ايوا وفقا لتقرير نشرته
واشنطن بوست جرين قالت انه في حال سيطره
الجمهوريين على الكونغرس فلن يذهب فيلسون
واحد اخر الى اوكرانيا لان الولايات
المتحده تاتي اولا على حد وصفها هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يدلي فيها جمهوريون
تصريحات تتعلق باوكرانيا قبل ايام خرج
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
كيف بتصريحات شديده اللهجه موجهه للقاده
قال فيها انه يجب على اوكرانيا الا تتوقع
الدعوه والمساعدات في حال نجاح الحزب
الجمهوري بالفوز بالاغلبيه في الكونغرس
وفي المقابله وعلى اثر هذه التصريحات
الحاده جاء انتقاد مستشار السياسه
الخارجيه السابق اوباما على تصريحات مكارت
عبر تويتر واصفا هذه التصريحات التي جاءت
في اوجي اخطر حرب اوروبا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
بانها تكشف عدم كفاءه ماكربي في ان يكون
رئيسا لمجلس النواب
الحزب الديمقراطي الذي ينظر الى المساعدات
التي تقدمها واشنطن لكي يفعل انها مساعده
من اجل مستقبل الديمقراطيه والنظام
الليبرالي نفسه والذي يضغط على
الاوكرانيين في نفس الوقت للتخلي عن رفضهم
الدخول في حوار مع الكرمل يرى ان انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه في الولايات المتحده هي
تصويت على استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا وهو
الامر الذي زاد من شده قلق المسؤولين
الاخرانيين بعد التهديدات الاخيره من جانب
كبار المشرعين الجمهوريين الامريكيين بقطع
المساعدات عن اوكرانيا وذلك في حال سيطره
الجمهوريين على الكونغرس الامريكي في
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه سلطان العبان
العربيه
اداره زعيمه الاقليه الجمهوريه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب قبل اكثر من
عام ونصف وحياه خلافه
اي فرصه للنيل من شخص سيناتور وعائلته
كذلك
الحزب الجمهوري لاي فوز الاغلبيه
تجمع الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
تشعلها ملاسمه لا تنتهي وان كانت حده
لهجتها اخف من ناحيه السيناتور
زعيم الجمهوريه لا هواده فيها منذ كان
رئيسنا واتهامه مرارا بالفشل في تمرير
اجندته التشريعيه لكن الفجوه تتسعت بعد
خساره ترامب للانتخابات عام 2020 وقت
الحمل انصاره للكونغرس
لتبدا المعركه
ومكانته الوظيفيه فترامب اكد عجز الحزب
الجمهوري عن كسب الاحترام او الفوز مجددا
بقياده السياسيين مثل ماكونا الالعاب وفق
تعبيره محملا اياه ومسؤوليه فقدان
الاغلبيه بمجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
العرب
للجمهوريين يدعمها احيانا بتغريدات ساخره
على موقعه للتواصل الاجتماعي تروس ووصفت
بالمحرضه على العنف حين انتقد موافقه
كونان على صفقه لتمويل الحكومه مضيفا ان
لديه رغبه في الموت
ولم تتوقف صاله الرئيس السابق وجولته
عندما كان لنفسه بل تخططه للاستخفاف
بزوجته المولوده بتعيبان ووصفها بالمحبه
للصين فصول المواجهه الثنائيه جاءت ضربتها
اكثر تحفظا من جانب ماكونال الذي التزم
الصمت تجاه تغريدات ووصف اداء ترامب
بالمجنونه ورغم ان ما كان لا اعتبر ترامب
مسؤولا عمليا واخلاقيا عن اثاره احداث
الكونجرس الا انه لم يصوت لاذاته
لكنه كذلك ينتقد نوعيه المرشحين الذين
يدعمهم ترامب بالانتخابات النصفيه مؤكدا
انهم سيزيدون صعوبه استعاده السيطره على
مجلس الشيوخ وتحقيقه انجازا جديدا يتمثل
بصاحب اطول فتره خدمه فيها
[موسيقى]
في اول مقابله مع وسيله العالميه عربيه
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه في مقابله مع
العربيه ان ايران رفضت تمارس الماضيه
لاتفاق النوويه والوضع اصبح اكثر صعوبه
بسبب قمع نظام للمتظاهرين وافعاله ايران
المزعزع للاستقرار لكن العلاقات بين
بريطانيا
الى الامام
فساتين فيديوهات
سناك سناب
برجراف
اهلا بكم من جديد اكل ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان ارسل المملكه على
استقرار السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان على هامشي قمه الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر في شرم الشيخ واشاره الامير
محمد بن سلمان
ومن شرم الشيخ اعلن ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان لان المملكه ستخصص
مليارين ونصف مليار دولار من اجل مبادره
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر على مدى سنوات عشر
القادمه مؤسسات تستضيف مقرها الرئيس
الاخضر
عشر سنوات القادمه
الاحتباس الحراري بحلول عام 20 50 من خلال
نهج الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون يكون من
اوائل الصناديق الثروه السياديه عالميا
والاول في المنطقه الشرق الاوسط في
استهدافه وصول الحياه الصفري بحلول عام 20
50 مما يعزز دور الصندوق كلاعب الرئيسيه
في دعم الجهود العالميه في مواجهه
التحديات المناخ
كم هكذا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان على ان المملكه تسعى الى تمثل
الطاقه المتجدده 50% من الاستهلاك في 20
3078 مليون طن مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بحلول 20 30 من خلال تطبيق الاقتصاد
الدائري الكربون واطلاق عديده ومبادرات
الاخرى منها منصه التعاون الدوليه لتطبيق
هذا النهج وصندوق استثماري اقليمي مخصصه
لتمويل التقنيات الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون
مبادره الحلول والوقود النظيف من اجل
توفير الغذاء
كما قامت المملكه بتسريع اوتيله تطرير
وتبني التقنيات ومصادر الطاقه النظيفه
المتمثله باستخدام الطاقه المتجدده بهدف
اداره انبعاثات ومن موارد الهيدروكربونيه
وابراز هذه الخطوه
يمثل يتمثل في تتويج مزيج الطاقه المستخدم
في توليد الكهرباء في المملكه بحيث يتم
انتاج 50% من الكهرباء داخل المملكه
بالاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه متجدده بحلول
20 30
في مقابله مع العربيه شدد الرئيس الفرنسيه
ويجب العمل على تغيير طريقه مواجهه هذه
التهديدات
بسبب انشطتها النوويه وتحركاتها فهي تسعد
دائما الى تنفيذ مخططاتها تحت اطار دولي
يمكننا اضافه عقوبات ولدينا الكثير لكن
علينا التاكد من ان العقوبات ستحد من
تحركات النظام ولن تؤثر على الايرانيين
لذلك نحتاج الى تحرك جماعي وسارى ذلك خلال
الاسبوعين المقبلين ما اذا كنا سنضيف
عقوبات تنبي طموحات ايضا علينا التحرك
تجاه ارسال اسلحه ومعدات ايرانيه الى
روسيا
طلب الرئيس
الى مفاوضات حقيقيه واكد ان الجيش الروسي
خسائر فاضحه على جبهه دوناتس وانا قوته في
حاله تقدم في بعض مناطق الشرق والجنوب و
تجبر القوات الروسيه على الترجيح
وفي بعض مناطق الشرق والجنوب ندفع بالعدو
تدريجيا الى الوراء خطوه ونحن نتحرك
الامان
المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض
مستشار الامن القومي البيت الابيض
من جانبه ان الاداره الامريكيه تعمل على
مواصله دعمها للشعب الاوكراني وتعمل في
الوقت نفسه على فرض التكاليف على روسيا
التي تعمل بطريقه خارجه عن توازن القواعد
الدوليه
على روسيا طالما انها تعمل بطريقه خارجه
عن توازن القواعد الدوليه الاساسيه للطرق
التي لم يوقع عليها اي شخص اخر ولكن روسيا
فقط وقعت عليها
وفي المقابل على الرئيس روسير النادي 50
الف عنصر في الوحدات القتاليه بالاضافه
الى عشرات الالاف من المجندين لم يشاركوا
بعد في الاعمال القتاليه في اوكرانيا
المجندين لم يشاركوا بعد في الاعمال
القتاليه
العسكريه الخاصه الى ما يقارب 80000 عنصر
والبقيه في مناطق التدريب يجب الانتباه
لهم اين ما كانوا
رفضت كوريا الشماليه تصريحات الامريكيه
التي تحدثت عن توريدي بيونغ اسلحه الى
موسكو
من الصحه وقال نائب ومدير الشؤون الخارجيه
العسكريه في وزاره الدفاع لكوريا
لم يكن لديها ابدا صفقات اسلحه مع روسيا
كما انها لا تخطط للقيام بهذا مستقبل
جديده
رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه في قمه المناخ
بشرم الشيخ فيما جدلن جديد يلاحقه وهذه
المره على خلفيه تعيينه جبن وليامسين
وزيرا بالرغم من مزاعم التنمر على زميله
نائبه له في حزب المحافظين هذه الفضيحه
الجديده تتمثل في ارسال الرسائل النصيه
مليئه بالشتائم الى مسؤوله الانضباط داخل
الحزب في البرلمان
لاستبعادها نبا ومن بينهم وليامسان من
حضور جنازه الملكه اليزابيث مكتب رئيس
الوزراء كان على علم بالشكوى ضد وليام قبل
تعيينه لكنه لم يكن مطلعا على مضمون
الرسائل التي وصفها بغير المقبوله والحزب
يحقق فيها
ارسال هذه الرسائل التي ارى انها قد تمت
بسبب الاحباط والانفعاله ولكن اعتقد عموما
انه من الافضل كتابه اشياء لن تندم عليها
لاحقا وخاصه مع من يكتب من الزملاء اشياء
مهذبه وان كانت لتعبير عن وجهه نظر مختلفه
الرسائل كانت غير منطقيه سوكر ستار مره
زعيم حزب العمال المعارض دعا سوناك الى
اقاله جيفن وليامسين واصفا ياه بغير لائق
كوازير في الحكومه والذي سبق ان اقيل من
حكومه الترزامي وتم استبداله في عهد
جونسون عندما كان وزير للتعليم ومنذ
استلامه السلطه تعرض سوناك للانتقادات
كبيره بدءا من اعاده التعيين سويلا دراما
وزيره للداخليه بعد ان اعترفت باستخدام
بريدها الالكتروني الخاص مرارا للقيام
باعمال الحكوميه مخالفه للقواعد الوزاريه
الى قراره بعدم مشاركه في قمه المناخ في
مصر ثم تراجعه تحت الضغط وصولا اخيرا الى
فضيحه رسائلي وليامسن المسيئه
الجدل يلاحق السوناك منذ التعيينات التي
اجراها لاعضاء حكومته والتي اعتبرتها
المعارضه على ما تضعفه سلسله الانتقادات
هذه لا تبدو نهايتها وشيكه مع الترقب
الكشف عن تفاصيل موازنه جديده ستكون مؤلمه
لدافع الضرائب ومزود الخدمات العامه
العراق
بعد اخماد الحريقه التي استمر اكثر من عشر
ساعات تجري حاليا عمليات ازاله الانقاذ
للوصول الى المفقودين الذين يتواجدون داخل
هذا المبنى اكثر من 10 فرخ هسه متواجده
داخل محل الحادث
نبحث همم هسه عمليات البحث والتحري عن
المفقودين حسب ادعاء صاحب الشركات الحريق
تسبب بانفجار ادى الى انهيار اجزاء من هذا
المبنى الذي يقع على مساحه تقدره بالف متر
مربع ويحتوي على قبل لتخزينه مواد التجميل
والعطور الاشخاص اللي موجودين من ضمنهم
ابنها يعني 12 واحد موجودين لحد الان ولا
جثه ولا شفنا شيء
خمسه خمسه
جدا لكنه هؤلاء المفقودين ما يزالون
ينتظرون هنا على امل العثور على ذويهم من
بغداد وانتظر رشيد ال العربيه
في مصر وبعد اربع جلسات بدا في سبتمبر
الماضي اصدرت محكمه جنايات الزقازيق حكما
باعدام الطالب اسلام محمد فتحي بعد ادانته
بقتل زميلته في الجامعه الطالبه سلمى بهجت
مع سبق الاصرار
بقتل زميلته في الجامعه الطالبه سلمى
بهجتمع مع سبق الاصرار والترصد في جريمه
ارتكبت على مرمى حجر من هذه المحكمه
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده في محيطها ورضا
من قبل اهالي الضحيه عن الحكم رغم علمهم
بنيه المدان نقد الحكم طبعا هم في طاعن
طبعا دي اجراءات قانونيه لازم تمشي وضد
دستور بتاعنا يقدمه الطعن بتاعها وده عادي
الانديه لازم تجرارات قانونيه في الدستور
المصري عايزه سلمى ان شاء الله بعد بامر
الله بعد ما يتنفس حكم الاعدام على
الاسلام والد المحكوم عليه بالاعدام حاول
بعد رفع الجلسه رؤيه ابنيه لطمئنته لناحيه
الخطوات القادمه وتقدمه بنقد الحكم خلال
60 يوما من تاريخه ده واحد مريض نفسي ولهم
ملف في الصحه النفسيه ازاي ياخذ اعدام
مفيش فرع بيقول كده
اكيد في اخطاء في اي حاجه
الحكم صدر بعد اربع جلسات فقط بدات في
سبتمبر الماضي قبل ان يستقر في عقيده
المحكمه ان المتهم لا يعاني من مرض النفسي
وانه مسؤول عن افعاله طبقا للتقرير الطبي
تامر نصره العربيه الزقازيق